screenwriting contests you've been part
of them yep nobody brought them and you
run them okay yeah and your thoughts on
them what works people's due diligence
with them yeah I think you have to do
your due diligence with them and I think
that for me everything it's not about
the money money's nice okay it's nice to
win a contest if the prize is five
thousand or whatever whatever it is
there was only one criteria for me when
I was entering contest and it's the only
criteria that we have with stage 32 as
far as our contests of concern when we
started you know talking about the idea
of running a contest because we really
really did want to give riders an
opportunity the only thing that we
talked about was access and what I mean
by that is you can go win Joe's
screenwriting contest and you can go run
around and tell everybody you want Joe
screenwriting contest and you can put it
in a query letter and nobody is going to
care okay but you know if you win the
nickel or you you know you'd do well on
the page too you know I love the page by
the way the people of the page I think
of fantastic or if you win our contests
you are getting your script sent to
actual people in the business that can
move the rock in your career and if that
isn't what it's all about then you
shouldn't be a writer okay you should
you know go do something else because it
should all be it should be about getting
your career going if you're gonna spend
the money again into a contest even if
you don't win if the contest has any
sort of cachet that's okay if you're a
semi-finalists a finalist and you're you
you know now you're sitting at a
networking thing and you meet somebody
online and you you know that person is
your your networking and you're making
the right moves with that person as far
as you know cultivating that
relationship and you say at some point
oh and by the way script X was you know
a finalist at the page now it's like oh
well that's really interesting because I
know that contest and that contest
carries some cachet but as far as
actually winning or being a finalist for
me it was always about the I always
wanted to look at who would be looking
at my material if I made the finals or
if I won because some some contests they
take all the finals we do this actually
we take all the finalists and take all
their log lines and we send them to at
least 30 executives in the business and
these are
managers agents producers directors and
development and we lists who these
people are these are people that can get
things done our contest winner from the
blood list we you know we connected with
the blood list to do a horror contest
and the person I wanted is already in it
got got management's for the contest we
flew him out to Hollywood through the
flu to top three out to Hollywood put
him in front of at an event ten
different managers and producers and
then sent them off on meetings two of
them got wrapped one that the winner is
rep the movies and development that's
what you want out of a contest the
reason I entered creative world award
which led to you know getting my
representation was because they you know
if you finished in the finals they
pushed you out to a bunch of executives
in the industry and ironically it was a
famiglia again no connection being a bad
connection ironically it was actually an
agent in Montreal who got his hands on
my script through somebody else through
that contest that started this whole
ball rolling you know some kind of a
random thing but it was still somebody
that read the script became a champion
of it and and then it moved on through
all the networking I spoke about earlier
so to me it's all about access you know
if you're entering a contest because you
think some people will say enter a
smaller contest okay
enter something that just started
because your chances of winning of
better okay
it's a ridiculous ridiculous notion
because at the end of the day like I
said if it's Joe's contest and it has
300 entries and you won first of all
you're not going to know there's only
300 entries you're not going to know the
number you probably not gonna be full
transparency second of all that contest
is not going to get you in front of the
people that are going to move the needle
on your career the third thing is if you
take that contest win and you put it
into any sort of query letter or bring
it up in conversation if you're lucky
enough to be in a networking event where
there are people of influence there that
you know that you want to get in front
of it may even look worse for you
because it may look like oh well you won
Joe's but what you do in the nickel or
what you do you know what I mean so to
me it's it there is nothing more there
is
no you do you do your research and you
look at the contest they give you access
so for a new screenwriter at what point
do you think that it's what should be
their own internal gauge as to whether
they're ready to submit to even a very
small and I hate to like tear them but
lower-tier you know contest I rather you
take it first of all just going back to
the lower tier thing I rather you take
that money and put it towards a
consultant or really good coverage
because if you're getting really really
good coverage and you're getting the
response you want from that coverage if
that you know if you get back a
recommend or you get back a consider
okay and there's only minor nitpicks and
then again it's up to you to digest
those and to be honest with yourself
about whether those minor nitpicks are
reasonable do they make the story better
or not once you clear your head on all
that then I would say just go into the
more prestigious contest if you have a
budget go into the ones that offer
access you know you have to be honest
with yourself but I would much rather
people if you're gonna spend money to
have your work reviewed then to me
you should go I mean if you guys spend
your money like on that so whether you
take that money and get reviewed
you